veronika lukas manuela leinberger mutter
und vater des bäckerlehrlings ivan er
sein handwerk voller inbrunst ausübt
zum missfallen seines meisters
leidenschaft ein zentrales element beim
jungen dreigespann weitere ingredienzien
der bachelorarbeit lust humor
sinnlichkeit fortbildungs glas was ein
arbeits und es ist aber wie sich das
anfühlt wenn ich das alleine regiert ruf
und frauen sehr schön zeichnen und
australien
animation und assoziation aus teig
werden berichtet für die macher eine
logische konsequenz
ich denke mir das wie weit man gehen
kann
darüber hat sich das team beim
entstehungsprozess intensiv ausgetauscht
habe andere hätten bestimmt bedenken
gehabt seit diesem thema die finger zu
verbrennen thema es klappt was mich
überzeugt sind auf der veronika die
techniker und ihre grundidee
eines tages verspürte veronika ein
vehementes verlange nach körperlichem
genuss nicht mit einem partner sondern
mit einem accessoire dass ich im winter
kam es für bus worte gefunden
nächste woche kosten am 15
acht monate haben die drei feilt an
ihrem werk das von srf koproduziert
wurde
eines ihrer ziele einen unverkrampften
zugang zur sexualität und zum eigenen
körper finden und das soll auch das
publikum jeden alters
wer diese eigenwillige interpretation
der rapunzel geschichte selber erleben
will der film läuft im januar an den
solothurner filmtagen